doesn't matter it has nothing to do with
an actual demand they're not saying say
her name okay here's her name okay we're
good
no it has everything to do with
mob violence to permanently
shut out silence shut up even to the
point of
violence and death republicans and
conservatives
you know the deplorables the
irredeemables the fascists
the the trash that's what it's about
there's there's nothing you can say that
will pacify this mob
they want you silenced forever
there are now roadblocks in dc like
we're some third world country like
we're some tin pot dictatorship
right now you're trying to come in and
out of dc in certain areas you will be
stopped by a mob
that will check your car that will force
you to say things
and tell you just to get out of your car
because that's what you want to do when
there's a violent mob nearby get out of
your car right that's worked out so well
for so many of the other victims of the
blm slash antifa slash democratic party
[Music]
riots
so you see this guy's walking up to the
car he's kind of joking into the camera
he's getting in this driver's face this
driver is just a sort of like
sad looking white guy
[Music]
he's looking kind of upset where is
out you have a better chance hop out
leave your car here if you hop out you
got it
this guy looks like this guy's on the
verge of tears please snow guys come on
please no
why why he says it he says he's about to
cry
look at
i also love this shrieking hyena in the
background
listen to black women you say god you're
not making a good argument
for your for your request i don't i
don't
does everyone sound like you because i
don't if if that's the case
it's like that shrill white woman who's
shrieking in that guy's face
let's talk about cops killing black
people he was like uh huh
lady come calm down i think there's i
don't think the
primary problem here is necessarily
racial so much as
uh there's this cultural issue with
these young
shrieking women who are are not making
us uh
particularly amenable to listening but
the guy is listening the guy leans in he
says
what are you trying to say she doesn't
care she doesn't want to be heard she
just wants to scream
and then you see this guy coming up to
him intimidating him saying come on get
out of the car
get out of the car this is the kind of
thing you would expect
driving through a third world country
but it's not it's happening in america
not just some places in america
multiple cities not just multiple cities
our nation's capital
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts